for the latest mini election trip I'm
off to South Dallas to speak to Nigel
Farrar UKIP's leader his curly block in
a battle to become the party's third
member Parliament but is the seats still
looking winnable
how does he feel you can general
election campaign is going and what
might Roz do neck fails to win on May
the 7th so Nigel Faraj the polls showed
that the South Planet race is going to
be a very tight one do you have any
regrets about sounding here no none
whatsoever don't forget I still here in
2005 I've worked with this branch since
1999 to try and build it up we've got
local councillors county councillors and
we've really gone somewhere with this
branch of big membership and now I was
committed to doing it and do you regret
it or saying that you would stand down
as you keep leader if you didn't win
because this is the make-or-break moment
for you now
see is adding to the level anticipation
that's the right thing to do no this is
this is my Beecher's Brook and there's a
fence there I've got to clear it if I
don't clear it well you've obviously not
been as involved in the national YouTube
campaign as you would have been if you
chosen even maybe a more you keep
friendly seat do you think that's gonna
cause the party why there issues about
getting that vote chair hire well I
don't know I mean I was in yesterday
morning and I was in
farik had a very big public meeting last
night and I've been I wasn't able to
Middleton before I mean I'm driving
around but yeah I mean clearly I've got
to fight this seat this seats important
so I'm trying to balance the to see
you've obviously been around we haven't
seen as much as don't of douglas
Carswell around the campaign why do you
think that is what even busy working on
Clarkson that's his number one
commitment and just as Marc reckless is
fighting hard in Rochester and strewed
but you will see more of Douglas in the
next three weeks because you saw
reckless and Mark reckless appear your
campaign laws but those cars were I
didn't know but he's on question time
tomorrow night we've done a few of aides
coming down here in a couple weeks to
speak for me
and have you spoken to him about after
your the HIV remarks that got the media
into a flurry last were a few weeks ago
yeah of course you know he thinks we
should have a National Health Service
not an International Health Service does
he agree with you on those on those
comments about I've just quoted him what
he said yesterday we should have a
National Health Service not an
International Health Service and as
Douglas said if we were in Australia we
wouldn't even be having this
conversation
normal countries do not open up their
health services to people who fly in
who've never been to the country in
their lives and they link with it so
obviously health tourism is a problem
but do you see why people got a bit
wonder about that particular example yes
but if only people understand that it
was the Cameron government in 2012 that
changed the rules so that you know
people with no link with Britain could
fly and be tested and get drugs valued
at over 20,000 pounds yeah and frankly
at a time when you're saying the people
I'm sorry we can't afford this cancer
drug if anything that's acceptable so so
you're hoping to win here there's many
other seats where you keep aren't going
to win you know I'm sure even you would
accept that what would you say to those
people do you think they should tack
vote to keep vote tactically vote you
keep supposes oh I don't think I don't
think you can't vote as I minded to vote
very tactically spilner smoothly because
but most of them have made the
transition they've come to you Kip
already but there will be tactical
voting in this general election of
course there will be
I very much hope there is from our
perspective because clearly in those
seats in the north of England where we
are the challenge of a Labour Party I
would want conservatives to vote
tactically for us are there any
situations where you'd want people to
tactically vote conservative and
actually if you ask you get voters you
know if you ask you get voters who come
to you get from the Conservatives which
I hasten to add is a minority of our
votes but if you ask them about their
attitudes and going back to the
Conservative Party it's a Diddley
percentage that will even consider it
and which you know I would they I
believe yeah we've just seen the
conservative manifesto the same pledge
is the same promises as five years ago
all the things they failed to deliver
why would earth would anybody want to go
back
and obviously first-past-the-post is not
a system that does very well for you and
which electoral system do you think is
the fairest well I think I mean I very
rarely at wrigley much the Roy Jenkins
said in his career but when he we had
the Jenkins Commission which Blair set
up to look at the future politics in
this country and they concluded that the
av+ system kept the benefit that the man
or woman continues to represent
Guildford and people know who the MP is
plus you have a second ballot paper
whereby if you're you know if you're
high Tory living in Sheffield it's still
worth on a rainy Thursday evening going
down because at least your vote will
count for something
so in 25 days time you could be the MP
for south theatre or you could be just
now as far as MEP and what's next to you
thing the Sunday Times reports that you
might be looking at a television gig
with Fox News is there any truth to that
I've heard so many rumors and they said
I would be moving to New York to work
for Fox and Musante people reported I
was gonna become a house husband so
there's all these different views like I
don't want to and you know the pose
obviously they were you had the 11
percent servation pole then it's been
looking a lot cuz it's still within the
margin of error and as it does it worry
you at all I'm getting on fire in the
campaign I think we've got momentum
behind the u-clip campaign I'm seeing it
particularly with younger people they
were quite excited about you given about
change last thing what do you think the
biggest problem you've got to face with
your campaign here the biggest problem
I've got to face is that there are still
a large number of people who whilst they
believe in everything I'm trying to do
are slightly entrenched in their voting
habits that it's breaking that breaking
that's important but but the real king
the real key is between one in four and
one in three of the pledges we've had on
the doorstep are from people who didn't
vote in 2010 and in some cases haven't
voted for 20 years but in some cases
I've never voted in their lives and the
real challenge is getting them down to
the polling station getting people to
put posters up as well a lot people want
post but symptom didn't want to get
egged they said well people are nervous
yes
That's not me they pretend there is a
vitriolic campaign against be going on
predominantly people bused in from
outside but there's been some very
unpleasant things said and done here in
the last week that's it for this mini
election adventure join me again soon to
find out how the election is being
fought in a different part of the
country find out more at mini election
co uk